so iak is as a movement is often
formulated in contrast to EA effective
altruism
MH what do you think are the pros and
cons of effective altruism what's
interesting insightful to you about them
and what uh is
negative right I think I think like
people trying to do good from first
principles is is is good we should
actually say and sorry to interrupt we
should probably say that and you can
correct me if I'm wrong but effective
altruism
is is a kind of movement that's trying
to do good optimally where good is
probably measured something like the
amount of suffering in the world you
want to minimize
it and uh there's ways that that can go
wrong as any optimization can and so
it's interesting to
explore uh
like how things can go wrong we're we're
both trying to do good to some extent
and we're we're both trying we're we're
arguing for which loss function we
should use right yes their loss function
is sort of Hedon right uh units of
Hedonism like how how like how good do
you feel and for how much time right and
so suffering would be negative heatons
um and they're trying to minimize that
but to us that seems like
uh that loss function has sort of
spirous Minima right you can um you know
start minimizing shrimp farm pain right
which seems not that productive to me um
uh or you can end up with wireheading
where you just you know either install a
neurol link or you scroll Tik Tok
forever and you feel good on the
shortterm time scale because you're
neurochemistry but on long-term time
scale it causes Decay and and death
right uh CU you're not being productive
whereas sort of eak measuring progress
of
civilization uh not in terms of a
subjective loss function like h
that's moving right and so that's not a
good way to measure our progress and so
uh but the thing is we're both trying to
make progress and ensure humanity
flourishes and and gets to grow we just
have different uh loss functions and
different ways of going about uh doing
it is there a degree maybe you can
educate me correct me I get a little bit
skeptical when there's an equation
involved trying to reduce all of the
human
civilization Human Experience to an
equation is there a degree that we
should be skeptical of the tyranny of an
equation a of a loss function over which
to optimize like having a kind of
intellectual humility about optimizing
over loss
functions yeah so so so this particular
loss function it's not it's not stiff
it's kind of an average of averages
right it's
like distributions states in the future
are going to follow a certain
distribution so it's not um
deterministic it's not like we're not on
like stiff rails right it's just a
statistical uh statement uh about the
future but at the end of the day you
know you can believe in gravity or not
you know but it's not necessarily an
option to obey it right uh and some some
people try to test that and that goes
not so well so similarly you know I
think I think
thermodynamics is there whether we like
it or not and we're just trying to point
out uh what is and and try to orient
ourselves and and and chart a path
forward given given this fundamental
truth but there's still some uncertainty
there's still a lack of information
humans tend to fill the gap of the lack
of information with narratives so how
they
interpret you know even physics is up to
interpretation when there's uncertainty
involved
um and humans tend to use that MH to
further their own means so it's always
whenever there's an equation it just
seems like until we have really perfect
understanding of the
universe humans will do what humans do
and they try to
uh use The Narrative of doing
good
MH to fool the populace into doing bad
yeah
I just I guess that this is something
they should be skeptical about in all
movements that's
right so we invite skepticism right do
you have an understanding of what might
uh to a degree that went wrong what do
you think may have gone wrong with
effective
altruism that might also go wrong with
accelerationism yeah I mean I think you
know um I think it provided initially a
sense of community for you know
engineers and intellectuals and
rationalists in the early days and um
seems like the community was very
healthy but then you know they formed
all sorts of organizations and started
routing capital and having actual power
right they have real power they
influence the government they influence
most AI orgs now I mean they're
literally controlling the board of open
right and look over to anthropic I think
they'll have some control over that too
and so I think you know the Assumption
of eak is more like capitalism is that
every agent organism and metaorganism is
going to act it own in its own interest
and we should maintain sort of
adversarial equilibrium or or
adversarial competition to keep each
other in check at all times at all
scales um I think that yeah ultimately
it was the perfect cover to acquire tons
of power and capital and unfortunately
sometimes that uh that that corrupts
people over
time